what has been seen okay cannot be unseen
it's like toothpaste
if you squeeze it out of the tooth you
can't get it back in what has been seen
gonna be fun
see what I spin seed you're never beyond
see boy you better look awakened son cuz
this is gonna be your face back to this
medical once you've seen it you cant
unseen it unless of course I just hurt
alright let's review some amazing can't
be unseen one all right forget most
popular therapists more like the rapist
oh Sh
oh [ __ ] that's actually really I didn't
I didn't know that hey it looks like a
duck [ __ ] yeah I think that dramatic
intro of this video doesn't really
reflect the rest of the content doesn't
it I asked you pros on Twitter
[Music]
Donald not dumb
[Laughter]
god dammit all right this is good one
okay it looks like one arm one arm one
leg one leg but really it's two arms
Superman cape two legs and Superman I'm
finally something decent work good job
good job now that's how I'm gonna look
at exit signs Tom Cruise has a tube in
the exact center of his mouth cannot
unsee
wait a manic oh my god Oh
oh my god oh my god oh this changes
everything I have ever learned about
myself goodbye
[Music]
Nintendo 64 totally looks like a koala
fine fine another one why does that it's
not even funny
it's naughty I'm just [ __ ] Jesus
Christ this one is great I remember the
first time I saw this on I was kind of
like whoa what the [ __ ]
cuz there's actually like a bear in the
Toblerone a mountain nice nice little
hint they in a hidden thing there
someone pointed out to my friend that
her dog's forehead has the Batman oh my
god that's amazing I got a check Edgar
the simple and I might be able to sell
you alright whatever get alright sends
down stands to standstill jeez okay okay
I can't
awful [ __ ] sake you're useless giant
Anthea their legs look like panas Oh
what this caterpillar looks like it has
a tiny penguin okay you know what that's
pretty [ __ ] dope alright that's
pretty [ __ ] cool
you need to frame that Apple and yeah
I'm telling you right now that's gonna
be worth million you need to frame that
Apple what has been seen cannot haze hey
Mickey Mouse loves that dick am i right
I always thought this was obvious I
don't I don't know I always thought it
was obvious that it you you know the
bunny the bunny [ __ ] I always thought it
was a thing you know I enjoyed it I was
like hey mom I'm eating [ __ ] and Mama's
like good yeah hell yeah
Iggy Pop's torso looks
all around me are familiar if you open
two windows and watch pixels and
Ghostbusters trailer side by side it's
the same goddamn movie here we go
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's [ __ ] beautiful
Sony Pictures what the [ __ ] I mean
they're both amazing movies so I'm
really glad that Sony find a formula
that really works so they can just
reproduce it you know and replicate it I
think that's really cool the a in
Samsung's logo is an upside-down V no
help
No
no it's a name that I think
[Music]
you